she's a Home Secretary fighting a battle
on two fronts accusations of ignoring
advice over an Immigration Center
questions about a security breach that
saw her sacked 12 days ago
today swella Braven came out fighting
the British people deserve to know which
party is serious about stopping the
invasion
[Music]
boldly defending her position it's been
said that I sent a document about cyber
security what's wrong it's been said
that I sent a document about the
intelligence agencies that would
compromise National Security it's wrong
wrong
refusing to back down earlier though she
had sent this letter to the home Affairs
select committee admitting to sending
official documents on her personal
emails six times it was only after she
by coincidence bumped into the chief
whip that swella bravman says she raised
the mistake and apologized four and a
half hours after accidentally sending a
highly sensitive email to the wrong
person the trouble is with these kind of
stories they do keep coming so it's now
when did she know she had reached the
rules who did she tell and it is a
distraction because it takes away from
the government's Central message which
is the grown-ups are back in charge and
we're trying to get the economy sorted
we are driving the Home Secretary has
certainly been accused of veering off
course before when Boris Johnson was PM
she threw her hat into the ring before
he'd even resigned I'm standing to be
the next leader of the conservative
party and was accused of freelancing on
policy at the Tory Party Conference but
she has sway on the right sacking her
could reignite Tory tensions says
celebrate made a mistake she's accepted
that she's apologized is that not enough
I think both the Prime Minister and the
Home Secretary are still not taking
National Security issues seriously
enough this is too much about that the
psychodrama amongst themselves and the
deals that they're doing amongst
themselves to try and stay in power
rather than putting the national
interest first and rather than taking
interest in the decisions in the
interests of National Security the Prime
Minister
spokespersonac has full confidence in
the Home Secretary and some of her
colleagues like Lord Frost have been
quick to defend her but others privately
including senior ministers have been
highly critical this is just one example
of one person who sat with her in
cabinet they say she's not up to it she
relies on others out of government to
advise her on what to do she's not good
enough
it is far from Clear if the Home
Secretary will survive this one Ally
suggested Rishi sunak may be comfortable
letting her fall on her Sword whatever
happens next swella bravaman's
reappointment has already come at a
political cost to the new PM Ali full
skew Sky News Westminster